we got a lot of fun and unique VR games
this past year many of which are still
improving in early access for this video
we're gonna focus on the best full
release VR games of 2016 thumper was one
of the best games this year period you
don't need PlayStation VR to play the
game but holy hell does it excel with it
while rhythm is a huge aspect of thumper
with thunderous taiko drum beats that
dictate the pace of the game this isn't
your typical rhythm game you control a
chrome-plated beetle blasting down a
super-fast luge full of dangerous
obstacles to dodge the path ahead is
filled with trans inducing colors but
the game also surrounds you in darkness
it's a trippy game to say the least
thumper is also brutally hard requires
intense focus and pushes you to form a
near symbiotic relationship with your
beetle in order to survive the threats
ahead vr injects a steroidal level of
immersion to the game the fact that
you're separated from the outside world
allows you to be totally enveloped in
its vicious and psychedelic convention
Reza Infinite is another rhythm game
that excels in VR you fly through a Tron
like cyber scape to hack a super network
as you can imagine the premise pairs
wonderfully with VR for the most part
the game is a rail shooter in VR you
look at your targets to lock onto them
but Reza infinite also offers an arena
ex mode which removes the rails entirely
area ex feels tailor-made for VR as it
lets you look and fly anywhere you want
[Music]
while edge of nowhere looks like a game
that you can play on your TV it's
actually a third-person adventure game
designed exclusively for the oculus rift
influenced by 80s horror movies like the
thing in aliens the premise is that you
crash your plane in Antarctica and
sustained a head injury in addition to
the monsters that you encounter through
the frozen tundra you start to
experience intermittent hallucinations
and it's not clear whether they're real
or induced by trauma your heightens
these tense moments it makes it feel
like you're being consumed by darkness
the game is extremely disturbing and has
some stirring set pieces which are
brought to life with eerie detail in VR
one game that fundamentally requires VR
is fantastic contraption the game
debuted with the HTC vive and showed
what room scale experiences could do
fantastic contraption is actually based
on a 2d flash game by the same name it's
asks you to build vehicles or
contraptions to carry a pink ball into a
pink area there are wheels and stems
that you can stretch to build car like
vehicles catapults and much more there's
almost an infinite number of
contraptions to build the levels can get
really challenging too for instance the
game often throws gaps for your
contraptions to overcome the beauty of
fantastic contraptions is that there are
always multiple ways to solve puzzles
fantastic contraptions also does a great
job of inducing a sense of presence when
you're physically on your knees tweaking
your contraptions you up there forget
that you're simply in your living room
it helps that the game has a colorful
and trippy art style that teleports you
to a whimsical world to one of the best
games to take advantage of room scale
and simply well fantastic
the last game on our list is superhot vr
which is the standalone experience
that's separate from the original
release super heart BR doesn't feel like
it was good for VR rather it feels like
it was born in it like the original
release time moves when you do and
you'll punch shoot and throw ninja stars
at red laguna lagoon with oculus is
motion track controllers everything just
feels right dodging bullets and slow
motion while snatching guns away from
enemies and firing back feels
indescribably cool this game will make
you feel like you're neo in the matrix
the game sports multiple levels that are
each divided into multiple stages when
you die on any one stage you restart the
level all over again this creates an
unforgiving process of trial and error
and you have to remember where the duck
when to punch and who to shoot first to
stay alive effectively changing these
movements together make you feel like a
beautiful ballerina of death the game is
not only super hot it's also super cool
[Music]
you